they were gonna let him go they did that
whole thing where hey we're gonna cut
this guy and they wait for the phone to
ring and then they worked out a trade
yeah and the trade can't go through now
because he tore his acl while
working away from the facility it makes
no sense whatsoever
but here's what does make sense no 2.183
million this year
for desean hamilton so he he joins that
short list
league wide two guys from the same team
juwan james
deshawn hamilton worst case scenario of
what happens when you work out on your
own
away from the team facility hey this
this is still
you know the the what do they say the
shock reverberations or whatever
it's still going through the league from
the player standpoint i i
i mean it's just it's amazing i think
that how few like i've talked to a few
coaches around the league
that they're shocked with how few people
and players on their team actually knew
about this type of stuff
i mean it's it's a real thing hey i'll
say it right here
i was drew brees was in the building
here right the other day right
drew brees i'm hanging out with him i'm
talking we're talking ball we're talking
about a bunch of different things
taurico brings up the juwan james
situation
all right and drew i i said this like
because he knew i'm gonna say this on
the air
but he was even unaware that you're
working out
for football outside the facility that
they could take the money away from you
so my point is that's because they never
would have done it to him i know
they never do it to the stars you're
right they don't do it to terrell suggs
when he's
like a defensive player of the year and
playing basketball you're right but
still nonetheless
the point is though drew brees is a nfl
lifer and has a lot of knowledge of the
nflpa and the union and all those type
of things
and that's just a it's a major tidbit
that's
you know in fine print that players just
don't
know about they don't know they was
they're
they're caught off guard and i'm shocked
by it i really am and i think that's one
thing where
leadership messed up a little bit for
sure there should have been more of a
big red email or fedex package that said
if you get hurt you don't get paid
outside the facility
um so i just found that fascinating for
even for drew brees right
i know that they got that warning i know
they got that warning you know who the
you know who the broncos players got
that warning from they got it from the
broncos
yeah they were given voluntary options
for workout programs right that they
could engage in on their own
with in red letters and underlined the
team is not responsible for any injuries
you sustain working out away from the
facility
and you know i've heard from a lot of
fans and fans are just wired to be
anti-player and that bugs me to no end
folks these are the people who make the
game go these are the people who are out
there
taking the physical risks taking the
risks
cognitively that they're going to have
long-term issues
when they are older more likely than the
general population
to to develop dementia and other
cognitive brain
problems but be that as it may
you know the the feedback is hey if i
get injured away from work
nobody pays me i only get workers
compensation if i
suffer an injury on the job and there is
some basic logic and appeal to that and
i look at it this way
if you are going to do the things that
your strength coach has told you to do
these are the workouts you should do and
you got a place
where all the stuff is there for you to
do those workouts
and you know that if you get injured
there your surgery is covered
your rehab's covered your salary's
covered
i i don't i if you're if you're anyone
other than a star
whose position is secured and whose
salary is going to be paid
no matter what you do away from work if
you're in that
broad category of guy who has to worry
about what may happen to me if i do
thumb my nose at the team and work out
on my own and get injured
you you just need to be in there yeah
that's all there is to it i mean that's
that's
it you know we've we've hit it yeah but
even with all that said that's what
makes it more impressive to me that the
union has been able
to leverage a better offseason
one team at a time because the teams
could have just sat back and said
hey go ahead work out on your own go
ahead go ask john james how that played
out
right i'm glad to see the flexibility
from the coaches who understand you know
what
last year we didn't do crap in the off
season we'll take anything
guys worked out on their own right and
and we still life went on yeah
the difference is going to be this chris
the teams that have the full and
complete
no concessions no reductions
no limitation offseason program are
those teams going to be better
that's what i that's what i look like i
look at new england and san francisco
right now and it seems like the
attendance is through the roof
and there's just not even a discussion
about it because shanahan and belichick
and i'm just saying this is just two i'm
using an example i know there's others
out there
but they have guys on their team that
are you know psychos and love football
and that's the only guys they've drafted
or signed a free agency and that's how
they
build their teams there you're right i
would think they're going to have an
advantage
and really i just wonder if this is
going to change off season workouts and
everything going forward in general
i mean obviously it is but obviously i
think if the coaches want to
you know take back some power here and
get the players back in the building
maybe this is what they got to do a
little bit too just to go hey okay no
more 11 on 11 drills no seven on
seven we could do one on one throw
routes versus air
work our techniques and drills do things
like that
maybe they're in the building a hair
longer during the week during these
times so they can have a little bit more
of extended walkthroughs
in 11 on 11 and 7 on 7 type stuff
instead of it being full speed and then
you get the incidental contacts and
people get hurt that way
maybe that starts uh just a new approach
to off-season training and football in
general
which you know i wouldn't be opposed to
i think there's certainly some benefits
to to doing it that way
chris correct me if i'm wrong yeah that
i need to invite you to do it but you
were there for it i remember
back during the time that you were
playing i would hear
all the time the complaint originating
with the offensive and defensive lineman
from off-season workouts 11 on 11. they
wanted to wear pads
yes because they were getting hurt right
by helmets hitting their unprotected
shoulders yes
because it became full speed
exactly without pads that's what those
off-season practices were
well think about like think about it
this way right you're doing 11 on 11.
and yeah everybody knows it's not full
speed but you still got a defensive line
coach in the back that's going
hey get through your gap get down get
low
and he's trying to impress this guy and
he maybe he's a young guy so now he's
going full speed
right and now the left guard who doesn't
want to go full speed and doesn't want
to get yelled at by his coach now
he's got to go harder because that guy's
going hard and then all of a sudden
it does it almost becomes like a contact
you know scrimmage without shoulder pads
and it does become dangerous and there's
no doubt there was players back then
that were like no i'd
i'd rather wear it because the
walkthroughs or anything like that
became a little too intense to what
you're saying so
that's maybe where they got to get rid
of that the seven on seven you throw a
ball over the middle
the safety in the corner and the wide
receiver run into each other
maybe they do do away with all that and
they make it more individual and drill
and walk through base as they go forward
you got the young guys trying to prove
themselves too they got that's right
that's right they'll go ahead and risk
injury with no pads on if it gets the
coaches
uh attention i i remember les sneed the
gm and the rams
on with the program a couple of years
ago when aaron donald was
holding out staying away from the
offseason trying to get his contract
snead joked you know it's kind of good
not to have him here for the off-season
because
a walk-through right right we can't do
anything aaron donald's on the field
he's throwing guys around that's just
what aaron donald does so that that's
that's what football players do yeah
it's not like removing the battery from
the energizer bunny
to take the pads off of the football
player the football player still is the
football player regardless of how much
protection he's wearing on his body yeah
that's right especially if he's a young
one too
like you said that they're trying to
prove and they didn't
you know they didn't do walkthroughs in
college a whole lot like
yeah you're you're 17 the hell with
walking we're gonna run we're gonna run
through it
you know in the nfl there's true
walkthroughs and like the young guys
always have an issue adjusting to that
they're like wait
we're really walking here like because
they're still running around and doing
that type of stuff
let alone if it's a real 11 on 11 thing
then the intensity can get
you know pretty intense and yes that can
cause issues
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports